sometimes when you're really really
lucky you get swept up you don't even
realize what's happening it's just
happening and then they'll say okay
let's do that again do the same thing
you did you're like what to do where am
i which has happened that's what you
live for when a scene plays you when it
just takes you away and sweep you away
and you were lost in it
it was an interesting thing because I
worked with Terrence Malick you know he
he would be asking me questions about
what do you think Holly would do in this
situation what do you think Holly would
do in that situation and we were magetta
ng to know each other
and each time I got a new draft of the
script there would be more things in it
that were like me
Holly Sarge's strawberry blonde hair
twirls a baton and I told Terry that I
knew had a twirl at the time and so he
went down to Hollywood Boulevard to some
music store and got a baton I did my
high school routine little did I realize
that what began in the alleys and back
ways of this quiet town would end in the
Badlands of Montana I really didn't do
much preparation for Badlands because I
kind of was young and impressionable and
and pretty much unformed and I was from
Texas and she was from Texas but that
was the film where I where I understood
that film could be art what's your name
I said mine Holly listen Holly you I
don't take a walk for me I remember the
day we were gonna meet Martin Sheen
Terry said to me you know he's you're
really too old for this but his agent
has been so nice I'm gonna we're gonna
meet with him today so but you know he's
still too old for the part but when
Martin came in he just was kit
Carruthers and it affected my Holly it
affected my my character and I learned a
great deal about acting from Martin
Sheen you know I think because I hadn't
really worked very much before that I
didn't know what the rules were I didn't
know how to prepare for a character I
was just twirling and wearing my short
shorts but it was a real turning point
for me because I I understood after that
how important the director is it was
kind of a yardstick that I went by I
thought okay it's nothing if I never
make another film
this has been enough because it was such
a powerful experience
I loved my character in the straight
story
oh she kind of broke my heart because
she was just such a pure heart you know
just a pure soul false teeth short hair
and a stutter I just adored her I had
prosthetic teeth it would change my
tongue position it would remind me to
stutter about her houses ever bruger's
oh that's nice yeah Pete Pete says my
Burt hasn't
she wanted me to go walking around this
little town of Laurens Iowa where we
were shooting and I said sure let's go I
told her I said I'm gonna I'm gonna
repeat everything you say I'm not making
fun I just need to get your the way you
talk and I'm gonna do a really bad job
for a long time so you just be patient
with me and she was and oh man it was
great we walked all over town and and I
met it she introduced me to everybody
and and I was starting to get her her
rhythm and David Lynch who directed it
said to me you tell me when you got the
accent and then we're gonna send her
away she's got a life she needs to go
and I said okay I think I got it she
wasn't to the outskirts of town and I
said wait stop her I can't do it get her
back so she came back and stayed for a
couple of weeks and by the end of the
show everybody was stuttering it was it
was just awesome it was awesome I loved
that character and
it was a it was a great experience that
I did a lot of research for my husband
Jack Fisk was also doing the production
design on that as well as on Badlands
and he had all this research and he had
these books of darae edgings and DeRay
did Bible stories and there were people
in really dramatic poses that it was all
just real you know people being eaten by
lions and thrown off cliffs that were
going through really intense things and
I looked at all of these biblical
itching and those were things that I
would start out or end Essene and one of
those melodramatic expressions and body
body language and then it really was a
wonderful thing I didn't know to acting
school along with the thing that I did
learn was sense memory and how to weave
your own life into your characters and
that's you know that's kind of been my
big that's what I've done I kind of
stayed away from everybody felt alone
and wrote poetry in the Attic and I
really got into to Carrie
of course it was all you know it was all
in the book we had Stephen King's
wonderful book so I could go to that and
pull details out of it but that was when
I think I first understood how important
researches
you know there's really only one Loretta
she'd never seen anything I had done she
just got to the picture and sister
that's her but that's Loretta and she
wouldn't budge that was a great
experience because I had her and I
followed her around went on tour with
her for a week and and she taught me her
songs we put the lyrics to her songs on
the lampshades
we would paperclip them to the
lampshades and go with her guitar from
one lampshade to another reading the
reading the music learning those songs
[Music]
that was just the most fun ever because
I had all those little brothers and
sisters who drove her crazy fighting and
you know fussing at each other I would
sometimes go to a set and I don't know
that I don't think I ever spent the
night but I would go and I never
remembered there I I fell asleep and
when I woke up I just felt like I I was
a lot closer to that that character and
I I did her accent or my version of her
accent and I did it I did it all the
time I did never got out of it so all
the crew members thought that I they
thought that when Loretta came to set
they're like wow she sounds just like
you [ __ ] but it's really the other way
right I can't do it so well now the
saddest thing about Coal Miner's
Daughter is that I had to stop being her
for you know for two months I had a band
I had a bus at all these great dresses
all these kids crazy husband
her daddy was played by levon Helm one
of the great great musicians he never
acted before and he was unbelievable it
was just he was stunning
Loretta's mother was played by a woman
named Phyllis boyens who was a mountain
singer who was just just incredible and
it was so much easier to work you know
they were so authentic I just had to
figure out a way to fit in and that's
not too far from whence I came
anyways I hated giving up that character
so much that was hard and that was the
saddest thing I made myself stop doing
her accent I was so funny I had her
since a humor and I that was the hardest
thing about the whole thing
oh that and showing the film to her fan
club I didn't worry about Loretta you
know cuz she'd helped me all the way
through but her fan club oh I was scared
when you're playing someone like Loretta
who's so well known is so loved that can
be terrifying except that I had her to
say you can do it Cissy
the character I play was a wife of a
young journalist and they lived in Chile
and during the coup her husband was
taken to a stadium where many people
were taken and many people were murdered
and he was one of those people and then
she was left alone in this city during
this upheaval and and you know they
never gave up and her mother-in-law and
her father-in-law Jack Lemmon played
played her father-in-law
it was incredible working with him and
in like 30 years later they finally got
their man and that was really it was
exciting to be a part of something as
real as that I mean he could have done
it to embarrass the government to make
look like they're arresting Americans
they are arresting Americans don't David
Holloway Frank huger counters this woman
of course things with Loretta I worked
on getting her voice right learning her
songs
even though Joyce was a real person
nobody knew what she looked like or who
she wasn't we had free I had freedom to
just create a character the main thing
was for me was just trying to illuminate
the scenes and what you know what was
going on because it was easier in one
some respects but harder and others
because it was real
my character was a woman who taught in a
school and stopped music in order to
lead all these magnificent young singers
and gregorian chants I had to learn the
Gregorian chants and so that was just
like so wonderful that kind of pulls me
into it I had to lose my southern accent
which was really difficult we're just
gonna have to take it apart when they
leave what the swing kid what do you
expect happy birthday here's a box
dragging around for a while he's a kid
he's like me wants it now tom is an
English actor theatrically trained he
could just blow me out of the room if
you know if he wanted to because he was
just so brilliant we were all there for
the right reasons we were all there
because we were obsessed with this
beautiful script and I learned so much
from from Todd Field we had no money so
we couldn't do a lot of the things he
wanted to do so when he would do a shot
a scene you know when we exited the
frame he would just hold the camera and
let it run out for a little while maybe
on a window with a shear blowing maybe
you know just a quiet room and then he
was able to use those to establish just
this quiet that wasn't their lives after
they lost their son that was a wonderful
that was just a wonderful film to be a
part of wonderful film to be a part of
yeah Madi Dara was kind of a kind of a
sad lonesome character you know she kind
of had a lot of loss in their life first
of all of course their sister and then
you want to know why I have your
sister's picture on my wall
I'm not stupid Phoenix though I take
that back how long was it going on she
was already married when I met you were
you just making up to me to get to her
this guy still disses her after all
those years so I try not to think of her
that much she said I loved working on
that project and of course Jessica
Chastain and Emma Stone and oh my god
Viola Davis Octavia Spencer it was that
was I love to do it when he sent me the
script I read it and I was like whoa I
kept waiting for mrs. Walters to do
something and nothing ever happened and
so I thought oh she must be in the book
I'll read the book so I read the book
I'm like she's not much in the book and
he said we're just gonna vamp you know
you can do what you want I want you to
be funny I was like oh yeah I've heard
this one before it's not written in the
script we're just gonna we're just gonna
BAM I came back with a pie I had baked
to say I'm sorry
I watched her eat well he didn't lie you
know we we did it it was fun and I loved
mrs. Walters and I decided that I should
be more like her
I flake Jewel and I got to work with
another really wonderful director named
David Lowery I had loved ain't them
bodies saints he was just different
talented and fabulous guy he's gonna be
around for a long time so when this
project came up it was still in in its
infancy and David is such a collaborator
he shared scripts with me
you know drafts of the script and we
talked about jewel I got to be a part of
the evolution and the birth of jewel
excuse me you know anything about cars
one of the things I loved about the way
David built our scenes is they unfolded
and you get to watch in real time them
flirting with each other and falling for
each other and then trying to make it
work I was excited to work with Bob I
met him once when I was a teenager and I
remembered it my whole life I said
remember it but he doesn't of course
because he was a big star and I was
nobody all acting is is illuminating the
human condition the beauty is that you
have all these different characters that
you get to explore and everyone is
connected to a different character for
different personal reasons I've met two
young women with Cary tattoos I just go
to them for that but you know if that
character meant something you know help
them through something to be able to
touch people emotionally like that is
really one of the sweetest sweetest
things that's a real little treasure
when people come up to me and say oh my
god I was going through the worst time
and that's awesome so and thought about
my brother and that's where it's at
but it's this